the coronavirus dominating the news yet
again in California the remaining
passengers on the Grand Princess cruise
ship will leave and go into quarantine
today at least 21 people on board have
tested positive for the corona virus and
at least two passengers are now suing
the cruise line meanwhile Wall Street is
looking to bounce back from a 2000 point
loss in the Dow Jones Industrial Average
that is the biggest single-day point
drop of all time and Italy has ordered
nationwide travel restrictions and
banned public gatherings after the
number of reported cases there grew to
more than 9,000 more than any country
outside of China throughout the
broadcast today we're gonna share the
newest numbers and critical information
on the outbreak and our lead national
correspondent David Pegg know is
monitoring it all for us David good
morning a lot of people are watching
this closely what do we know
Tony facts that were fear so here we go
right now there are more than 780
reported cases that's about more than
200 from yesterday morning the virus is
now linked to 26 deaths nationwide it
has also spread to two more states since
yesterday morning thirty-six states and
the District of Columbia are now
reporting cases you know the total
number of patients around the globe has
reached more than one hundred and
fourteen thousand I want to take you to
China President Xi Jingping visited
Wuhan that is the epicenter of the virus
there it was his first trip since the
outbreak began China recorded just 19
new cases overnight that is the lowest
one-day total since it started counting
back here in the US the CDC is now
releasing coronavirus test numbers just
8500 tests have been done in labs since
mid January here in the US now keep in
mind the Trump administration has said
there would be 4 million tests available
by the end of this week in fact last
night the vice president said that
private companies quest and LabCorp have
manufactured a test that is available on
the market today I want to tell you the
story of a man from New Jersey he is
that state's first coronavirus patient
he's 32 years old his name is James Kai
he thinks he caught the virus at a
medical conference in Times Square
he said his symptoms were watery isakoff
shortness of breath and
riah he spoke to our New York station
WCBS from his hospital bed as his
condition was deteriorating he says he
is in good health
take a listen so I went to the City MD
in New Jersey kurama's and they did an
x-ray they see nothing this viral they
was so quick
not even one week now my lungs is is
bilateral on both sides before this one
side people had to take coronavirus
seriously James said he had no
underlying health conditions before he
started presenting the symptoms we
checked with his family this morning he
is still alive but he's not doing any
more interviews right now we will have
more coronavirus updates throughout the
morning Michelle and David thank you